if it is an accident to law it would
mean that among other things the Supreme
Court would no longer have the power to
overrule government or ministerial
decisions than it deems to be
unreasonable
behind me these are thousands of
demonstrators that have assembled
outside of the Supreme Court they are
out here once again because they are
saying that if this bill passes into law
and if any part of the plan by prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu and members
of his far right-wing Coalition were to
pass them to law this judicial overhaul
plan that's been proposed that would
mean that Israel would be taken off the
road of democracy that it would be put
onto a road of autocracy the situation
for them is extremely dire they say this
is an existential threat to democracy in
this country and they say they will
continue to come out as long as it takes
to send a clear message many whom I've
spoken with say even if the bill does
pass they are committed to continuing to
come out you also have well over ten
thousand members of the reserves of
different branches of the army
reservists who are saying that if the
bill passes into law they will no longer
report or service that has caused a huge
amount of worry I'm on the top military
leaders who say that this could impact
military preparedness in this country
prime minister coming under pressure
from the protesters also coming under
pressure from of course members of
military reservists but he's also coming
under pressure from members of his far
right wing Coalition they would like to
see at least one part of his judicial
overhaul plan this bill passed before
the knesset breaks for its summer recess
that will happen later this month
uh foreign
foreign